it's about two hours for me they bled they
fell over they tore muscles one actor even
nearly got sick on set because of their costume
the bridgerton cast went through it filming their
second season of the netflix hit we're going
behind the scenes to check out just how painful
the bridgerton beauty treatment was number one
has anyone ever really liked wearing a corset
you must know it has weighed on me every day
simone ashley joins a long long line of actors
who endure the hardships of corset wearing which
unfortunately includes injuries ranging from
scratches to torn muscles she's been pretty honest
about her experience while filming explaining
i had a lot of pain with a corset too
i think i tore my shoulder at one point
not only was it painful but the accessory
made doing basic tasks more difficult as well
in the actress's own words because when you're
in a corset you can't put your shoes on there
were a few scenes where it was a bit couldn't
lift my arms up couldn't you know embrace us
her co-star nicola coughlin wasn't wrong when
she suggested there be corsetry acting awards
given to every single actress in the show
wearing one just for getting through filming
number two league struggles are real struggles
penelope's hair is so big because it's so full of
secrets it's big hair and apparently unpredictable
at times as well nicola coughlin has a massive wig
which also means it's a pretty weighty accessory
to carry around on top of your head not to mention
the added struggle of the tiara when she sports
it glamour is pain one of the biggest struggles
of wearing such a big wig though is losing parts
of it without even noticing the actress would be
minding her own business when suddenly a voice
from the set would ask did someone lose a curl
bits of penelope featherington's hair were
lost all around the set just another regency
aerodrama issue to worry about number
three the costumes cost and weighed pounds
all those crinolines and layers make for weighty
costumes but simone ashley had a particularly
heavy wardrobe well by the end of the series she
had a bit of an easier time moving around in more
lightweight costumes off the top of the season
was a real struggle because of the high quality
but heavy silks and taffetas used to help show the
closed offness of her character early on in the
show the costumes sported the more rigid and tough
fabrics great for storytelling but for ashley not
so much number four if you're gonna eat do so at
your own risk the worst part about my costume was
i couldn't really eat unfortunately this was
a lesson simone ashley learned the hard way it
was her first day of filming when ashley realized
that big meals and bridgeton costumes were bigger
rivals than the featherington and bridgeton
families the actress had mentally prepped
with a goal in mind okay first day as a leading
lady gotta eat lots of food be really energized
if this were a different show it's probably a
pretty good plan but when you're the star of a
regency era drama a beautiful and significant meal
of salmon hits the wrong way i realized when you
wear a corset you just don't eat it changes your
body i had a smaller waist very momentarily my
food was like up here after the lunch break ashley
realized what a mistake she'd made while she spent
the rest of the afternoon nauseous and on the
verge of getting sick for the rest of the day if
she didn't hate her corset before she definitely
did now just cool i am trying it is stuck number
five you do what you gotta do everyone keeps
their phones in their boots in bridgeton don't
tell you no one can say the bridgeton costume
crew didn't make the outfits worn on the show
very historically accurate but it did make for a
modern day struggle where to put the cell phone
there were no hidden pockets here so the actors
wearing boots did the best with what they had
now the boots themselves were okay on their own
but add a hard phone rubbing against ankle bones
and the struggle becomes far worse bruised bones
anyone as for those actors who were in heels well
that was a whole other issue and they had even
less options of where to tuck their phones away
number six heels on the bridgerton set may cause
the actor wearing them to fall over just ask
nicola coughlin she can speak from experience on
the first day fell over three times in the heels
the actress fell over multiple times on set in the
first season and even with all that practice she
toppled over filming in season two as well and
she was never doing particularly intense things
it could happen walking or just standing trying
to exist in the uncomfortable and unstable shoes
maybe the worst harm she did cause in them
though was to on-screen bff eloise bridgeton
aka claudia jesse season one saw the actress's
heel accidentally jabbing into jessie leaving the
actress bleeding on set they didn't fire me thank
goodness number seven this princess curls were
real it's not a pub on the bridgerton set this
vibe count is known as jonathan bailey the face
of perms you do what you gotta do for the job even
if it requires sitting to have your hair treated
for hours to spruce up its curlitude oh and we
can't forget the sideburns that the actor grew
himself which have become more commonly known as
his lamb chops oh but the prep didn't stop there
bailey had to get that hair primed and prepped
every day if bridgeton has taught us anything
it's that living in the regency era is not easy
number eight this definitely wasn't part of the
style back then the season two set of bridgerton
included a new accessory that's taken the globe
by storm over the past couple of years it's
covered now so we have we have masks on so
it's slightly different to the first season while
they removed them on set when performing filming
during a particularly tough time the pandemic
meant masks were used often making it even harder
for the actors to breathe who let's remember are
already struggling to breathe with those corsets
number nine only cool people wear capes okay
well these aren't exactly capes but the actors
were using coats and scarves as if they were on
top of everything else they had to worry about
every actor on that set had to take extra care
not to spill anything on their outfits meaning
it was time to add more and more layers whenever
someone needed a snack or pick-me-up coffee no
action could be taken until those costumes were
protected let's just say this wasn't a help for
the performers who already had a tough enough time
moving around the set bulky and restrictive layers
the unfortunate bridger can cast reality number
10 they don't wake up looking so put together
they do wake up shockingly early though nicola
coughlin was up and ready to be fetched by a
driver at 4 45 a.m yes the 4 45 before the sun
comes up there's a lot of work to be done to
transform this into someone who's ready to go to a
ball in in regency london so yeah about two hours
the filming day couldn't begin until the
actress underwent her two-hour hair and makeup
transformation the beauty expectation struggle is
real number eleven just how much pain is beauty
phoebe denivore knows the corset and regency
era costume drama well especially considering
she wore over a hundred different dresses in
the first season each one of which contributed
to her unfortunate scabs and wounds all over
her back these injuries only got worse until
finally the actors could be relieved of wearing
the painful outfits every day number 12.
let's crunch some numbers season two of bridgerton
did not hold back first off the costume department
saw a whopping 7 500 pieces made from scratch in
just five months every episode averaged a solid
90 costumes while the second episode of season
two put them all to shame with its 146 handmade
outfits with all this work it's not too much of
a surprise that the full costume construction
team was actually composed of people from around
the world all of whom sent their work to the head
costume house in the uk once the pieces arrived on
set the head design team checked over everything
making sure every detail was taken care of not a
ribbon was out of place and it shows bridgerton
never fails to be a feast for the eyes but not
without causing the actors some serious struggles
their bodies are thanking them every time they
can rid themselves of those restrictive pieces
what do you think would be the hardest
part about their regency era clothing